ok ich immer noch etwas gekostet 20
feile und jetzt para kiri leute das
death match startet
service s kids und auch an die zuschauer
von wenig ein herzliches willkommen
aktion jump league event wir sind mit
128 spielern in einer runde und wir
haben jetzt 30 module die uns vom finish
trennen die runde startet und wir
kommentieren das dual heute leider ist
ihm verboten das heißt wir müssen
getrennt spielen aber das macht ja nix
wir können hier trotzdem gut abschneiden
und in deathmatch sich leute werden
jetzt wieso nicht gleich begegnet denke
ich mal ne y/y fragt massa war in den
ersten kämpfen hast ich habe schon
direkt im ersten spiel echt mega
aufgeregt erster check point man auf
geht's ja jetzt was ich dabei bin
es gab ja schon mal sowas erstmals
wieder eingeladen ist mit livestream
allerdings legen auch ein bisschen merke
ich jetzt gerade
ja ich hab noch kein problem gehabt
liegt vielleicht daran dass meine
connection zu schlecht ist
herr papa 50.000 ab 100 von glasfaser
schlecht also bisschen adrenalin ist
schon da muss ich sagen die selben
zusammen normal
ja das hat sich der bis am ende eine
menge stuff an bei 30 modulen
ich hab mich war man sich hier so
herauskristallisieren ob möglich nein
ich bin mir wirklich gefällt ja ja nein
richtig weg man trotzdem sehe ich mich
nicht den richtigen ort alter mann muss
auch teilweise an importieren glaube ich
mache einfach so viele kräfte jetzt habe
ich den wirklichen checkpoint nächster
checkpoint incoming da gehen schon ein
paar ordentliche freiheitsdrang auf
jeden fall und ich bin mal 12
ich habe keine ahnung wie man das unten
steht unten drin
8 19 ok 320 jetzt kommt einer tag bei 24
was los bei dem mann der sich bei der
geht gut ab so dass schon dampf
mir läuft es gibt ja sowieso immer mega
hype also leute wollten nicht wissen wie
ich mich bei der ware aufnahme fühle ist
sowieso schon immer eher aufgeregt bei
der wahrung aufnahme [ __ ] my life man da
bestehe nicht ab obwohl ich hatte auch
26 prozent was ist das hat allerdings
auch fünf leben natürlich wird im
ko-system reinbothe mit ein paar kumpels
hat einfach hier raus bist du alter das
war horror
ich habe immer noch keinen keinen job
nein man jetzt nicht nur wünsche beim
modul zehn prozent dazu 28 jetzt aber
das was jetzt gerade ist es mag ich
nicht weil ich glaube ich einen film an
ich glaub ich hab vergessen kann ich
jetzt rück position bringen
da kann ich ehrlich wäre das denn mit
nein man es gibt so dem sprung
nein ja wenn du so oft verpasst dann
hängst du dann halt mal
konzentrationsschwierigkeiten drei tage
später
40 aber guck mal der 150 jetzt also dem
was richtig gegeben gut gas die box
gab es gar nicht so blöd gewesen hoch
liegen wie an mit gelassenheit ist ja
schön wenn man sich von einem stalker
sehen kann sich jetzt dass ich bin's
politik millionen partien kennst du noch
nach den alten melonen part ja also
diese einzelnen institute über melonen
sind
ich weiß nicht wirst du meinst du wirst
sehen
ich muss erst mal hier ich muss mich
ganz auf meinen gameplay konzentriert
macht das ja ein bisschen aufhole wir
nehmen gerade mal sieben minuten auf und
die leute 60 prozent gleich aber da ist
alles länger dauern glaube ich also wenn
die harten rüberkommen ich die zehn
harte module miteinander wie heftig ist
es eigentlich wie viel prozent das tut
47 39
langsam läuft service gefühlt come for
heart stehen dann habe ich schon genug
stoff sei nicht das erste mal so richtig
aussortieren man kann sich auch gold
müssen wir darauf endlich richtig viel
gold matellia hatten immer so ein
bisschen gold und kann man nie was
anfangen aber hier wie ihr dürft locker
erreichen
ok habe ich die 17 schon das erste hard
modul das war richtig wieder
wahrscheinlich gegen die super hart oder
so bauleiter modul 17 schon das erste
hard modul sie stets - prozent 50 ist es
ja ich habe 44 gibt es gib gas ich hole
auf jetzt so langsam essen junior
kompaktfahrzeug weg das ist auch wichtig
zeug wieder aufgeräumt hast so viel
ramsch dabei war damals richtig krass
ich noch kein einziges eisenteil dieses
mit eisenteilen nicht aber ein eisen
habe ich vielleicht hier also sind wird
auch mega viele die ihr schwert das war
knapp ja stimmt als letztes mittel durch
die kräftig sein
also wird man ich hab ich dich hab ich
noch nicht aber ich hatte aber was auf
jeden fall kein problem sein wird das
essen ja okay also wenn jetzt einer
kommt und so höhe jemand essen dann
sollte man schon seine liveshows
überdenken
ich kenne ganz ein paar ziemlich alle
kinder baten die subsidiar kennedy hat
alles so heftig obsidian säule ohne
risiko dass sie wie die im entstehen
wenn der drachen
ich glaube so ein paar bin ich gerade
das ist mir auch noch einig bei uns hier
bei 50 prozent
51 jackpot mitnehmen und zurück und
jetzt bis zu verhaltener
jetzt könnte es sein dass ich bei hard
bin wo ich hab meine erste eisenbahn
soli musst du ihnen hoch springen und
hat mir ganz viel leitern drinnen und
danach musst du aus dem springen das ist
richtig gefeiert es richtig schwer
die nerven kasper ich habe von kaspar
ich bin der nerven caspar
es kennt mich nerven kasper okay die
obsidian solle ist mir auch komplett neu
bist du das schon echt dass du dieses
quartett über diesen insel voll
weggesteckt
da habe ich richtig verpackt vor dem was
sie diese diese sollen die erste
anstellung platz bestehen die vor dem
vor dem ziel
nein ich bin schon wieder ganz gut ich
kann kann ich denke lewis spielen ist
schon aus einer säule nein' noch außen
witze richtig schwärmen
okay das ist machbar hier kommt das ist
machbar hier oktoberfest auf endlich
endlich auch genau in diesem moment mit
entspannter ich habe auch noch einen
chef scheint da habe ich schon einen bus
habe ich auch hält doppelt so eines hat
bei dieser leitern jammern alter wie
eklig alter bei dieser leute hab mich
voll rein geschissen gerade die kräftig
77 prozent hat schon eine einfach was
ist es denn die ganze die anderen
springer bei mir geht's jetzt soll was
ist ein bisschen besser
aber immer noch nicht so wie es laufen
sollte aber es geht 58 prozent was ist
denn los auch gott ich bin oben auf der
säule also ich bin auf dem letzten
obendrauf jetzt muss ich nur den sprung
nehmen
check point habe man kommt nicht auf die
leiter bei diesem sprung vorderseite das
ist es ist toll einfach wonach ich jetzt
hier hatte sinken sinken gold echt schon
klassischer westfront den nächsten
checkpoint go go go go also am anfang
ist mir davon gezogen junge okay ich
weiß aber dass man sagt jetzt auch
gerade nicht so vielleicht hier lang
ich glaube da lange sechseinhalb stunden
später als bisher in den top score
partner es bald in diesem scoreboard 760
habe ich jetzt gerade 74 hat der letzte
da unten steht macht wenn ihr wenn ich
einen score bekommen würde wenn ich ganz
geil aber ich habe jetzt schon den
ganzen stoff den kisten drin ist es halt
so die sache ja so schon verloren
ja also ich hab immer schön hermann es
regeln falls du sie kennst zu voller
rüstung immer nur jane harman ziehen
ja die leute fangen jetzt an so im chat
zu schreiben wenn ein paar lehnen sie
aber so zurück und im angriff darf man
sicherlich 71 prozent ich hatte so den
lauf meines lebens ist kacke hier auf
der höchsten stufe
ok bei mir geht's modul 23 72 and
counting glaubst du gibt es in der fulda
sie bekommen keinen einzigen die ja
gesehen 24 modulen full die ja nicht
vielleicht ein ganz glücklicher der sich
die akkus macht aber dann auch nur wenn
er kein die schwerter
ich bin nur 73 prozent mister es sind
schwierige 96 ist anders
er soll dem ziel man logo leuten zeit
bis der dm starter distance persons und
dann steht man ebenso 54 noch
44 jahren 45 minuten weiter spiele halt
echt cars tango gogo alter ja man nicht
diesen part schatten 74 prozent ich will
ins scoreboard doch lasst nein als ob
ich hier fehle gab das tut weh junge ist
bitter ist es bitter profis knacker
reached the global account und bleibt
der gleiche stoff ist kaputt die disco
sein oder wie keine ahnung denn die
kammer hat direkt grafiken nein es
reicht nicht
ich bin bei diesem modul kennst du
kennst ein paar hart module wenige
kennst du dieses einem modus von so
steinblöcken ganz ganz außen springen
musste wurde so ein ultra weiten
schrägen sprung hass auf gleicher höhe
da bin ich gerade das mega tricky der
letzte sprung ist voll schwer bei diesen
eine mit dem mit obsidian soll hast du
ja sehr gut als möglich wieder auf die
anderen sie bei 80 prozent
leute ich hänge ja und ich hänge hier
ich hier
das modul danach kenne ich das ja doch
was danach kann ich bereue was ist denn
das mit den türen das ist richtig
schwierig oder damit damit damit der
versteht man versteht man sich jetzt
aber eva 88 jahre auf dem buckel alter
am 20 ok ja ich habe noch immer kann man
einfach mein leben ich habe bei modo 24
dass es richtig ist dass also das ist
mit diesem ja das ist eines meiner us
modul leiter bei welche module bist du
gar nicht ich 64 prozent auf 4 17
nach der wahl aber es hat mich fertig
und wiederitzsch einer okay gut jetzt
packen das jetzt packen was leute kom
kom kom kom kom kom kom jawohl modul 25
5 prozent treffe ich noch vom scoreboard
und jetzt
er gibt gas sinken armin apple dieses
sounds immer noch also das was von der
sucht die wenn der so lange braucht um
zu finden schon bald wissen alles
übelste wie willste dollar bot koller
alter nicht alle module mal durch mega
viele conference call nicht mehr packen
ich muss gar nicht drin ich sortiere
mich schon mal 15 sekunden
ich habe keine eisenspitzen habe ich
alles rein 80% okay ich komme manchmal
hin
wie wird das jetzt mach ich immer noch
den fans gekostet
20 feile und jetzt para kiri leute das
death match startet gefragt werde so
richtig loslegt kann ich ja noch ne
kiste mitnehmen ich bin noch weiter
gerade im job man fling fall schaden
wenn ich jetzt aus der welt fallen auch
schaden krieg dann reicht's aber nicht
ich bin gestorben instant als ob direkt
habe ich irgendwie kit mit dem leck ok
alles lag des todes er versuchte ihnen
sicher zu bringen das von anfang würde
sagen da sein ich wäre es legte stone
ist okay ich hab meinen ersten kiel
geholt habe gar nichts man ich gehe hier
um und wird verzaubern aber ich kann
nichts machen lag killer erden los junge
ohne ja ich nehme die kills mit alter da
gibt's nichts
ich hab voll angst dass ich wenn ich
mein schwert hut zaubern black und an
tötet mich jemand im black das ist ein
weg ist das wäre echt bitter oder gar
nicht mehr hier vorne ist einer der leg
nicht
ich lag auch nicht okay jetzt anzugehen
alter habe ich nicht gezählt
ich weiß ich weiß nicht was da los ist
ich bin selber gestorben obwohl er kein
gegner war man das ist richtig schlimm
ich glaube ich dass ein eishockeyspiel
erst ein bisschen auf kill abstauben
müssen defensiv weiß jeder kiel den du
einem anderen masters einmal mehr für
dich aber es bringt ja viele scheiden
aus gerade nur 290 player
drei hast du noch 33 ist die boarder
vorne ist einer
die boarder kerner ich mir den da hinten
holen bekommen
ich habe sechs kills drei leben aber ich
glaube ich kann ja ok
den kann ich mir holen
erhan dogan aber ich habe 17 kills
dreileben archivs zwei leben oder um
kommt an damit die akkus erst mal eine
runde laufen würde ich sagen nein
absolut nicht gar nichts machen ich kann
nichts machen
bei mir geht es halbwegs mir geht
überhaupt nicht danke an unsere
connection dieser stelle ja also die
leute hackl hin und her aber man kann
sie treffen kaum kaum raum
jetzt habe ich zu zwei herzen weg durch
den links da läuft erstmal noch ist das
glaube ich kann ich nicht wirklich
machen
das war richtig eklig mann 22 leben nur
noch etwas was was war das niemand ist
bei mir auf einmal habe ich nur noch ein
herz das geht mir auf die ganze zeit da
frag ich aber auch zwei leben man nur
noch zwei
die ganze zeit niemand ist bei mir ich
bin gekommen um den schaden kann aber du
kriegst keine pflanzen oder wie ist es
irgendwie nicht mehr als einer von den
deutlich abstauben könnt ihr abstimmen
können regie bei der comic bad fucking
ist ein jet der holt mich darauf mich ob
ich halte es jetzt ein herz pocht nein
ich habe noch ein leben ein junger gott
ich hatte mein leben wie viel leben hast
du noch 122 jetzt direkt die wollen mich
jetzt alle haben wir noch ein leben wie
ich muss mein leben reinalter ohne witz
um ein leichter fehler
gerade ja ich habe auch noch ein leben
gott das wird das nein das ist nicht
cool das nicht cool ein verzaubertes
nicht gerade würde ist ein letztes leben
nicht noch zwei tage dann einfach einer
bottroper da kommt noch mehr motto man
diese tage der mich so zu tode alter
leben locker dass ich am anfang verkennt
man verpasst ja aber das ist auch
natürlich war es geht um leben und das
stimmt schon
natürlich ein bisschen postbank jetzt
lag so eklig auch neblig lag des todes
locker bin ich tot
glock habe ich kann ich es nicht kann
ich essen niemand bei mir ich kann die
essener fans dort was zu essen einfach
gott ein leben auf kommando zu schade
gekostet der typ target mich immer noch
was das für ein bastel hat nicht
er heißt überhaupt du warst ein herz auf
einmal als ob als ob man mir auch die
ganze zeit wie schon freudig lauf
geradeaus niemand ist bei mir auf einmal
ein herz dann tot
kenn ich bin okay leute das wort von mir
mich um die lex umgebracht ein paar kids
gebracht aber bitte also kann man es
unspielbar sondern naja aber dank führst
du schon so weit weg auf jeden fall
wenig folge april noch mehr sehen wollt
der ist ja offensichtlich bisschen
länger am leben
bis dann hört rein macht's gut und ciao